are recorded now. So welcome everybody to the Zoom call. It is the first of October, excuse me,
first of August, 2018. We've been doing this for almost a year now. So we have nearly 52
videos for you to catch up on if you just started with our clinic. And we'll have a quiz on that
next week. Look for that in your email box. So everybody will be all caught up, right? So here we are.
We have lots of questions to get going through. So let's get cookie right away. So really good
ones had come in. The first one says, I realize and it has been re-emphasized to be by your
staffs at the right for she takes a few months to get started to show noticeable results
with prostate cancer with any cancer. Why is that? So let's stop right there. So first of all,
understand that any therapy, whether it's chemotherapy, radiation,
or alternative therapy, it does take time to heal from that. Now, obviously more radical therapy,
like we're going to remove your prostate, could reduce the person's PSA in a prostate cancer
like immediately, or we're going to remove your colon. Well, now you debulks that cancer.
You have immediate changes to the body versus doing chemotherapy and it could take time for that
cancer to die with the chemotherapy, more direct hit with the radiation. So the more invasive
the therapy, the quicker the result that you're going to have, what the rife machine is doing.
Let's not overemphasize what it is doing. It's not going in there and magically killing all the
cancer cells. That's not what the rife machine does, even though maybe that's what royal rife thought
it did. But in truth, it's not that easy. Otherwise, nobody would have cancer because you just get a
rife machine and it wipes it out in a week and you're all better. Well, it just doesn't work that way,
and it doesn't work that way even with chemotherapy. So sometimes you do chemotherapy. It could knock
down the cancer and kill millions of cells and then the cancer just gets angry and grows faster.
Well, the same thing can happen with any therapy, even a natural therapy. So don't have unrealistic
expectations, but in the same sense, have have realistic hope that I'm going to do the right things.
And I want to see the results that I'm hoping to see. It takes time to heal. So the answer to
why is that? It takes time for your body to heal. The rife machine is helping to alkalize the tissue.
It's helping to stimulate the immune response against the cancer and the cancer cells don't just
magically die that fast. So it does take time. Does it have to scan that log before it figures out
how to find the cancer cells that begin to deal with them? You're not understanding how it works.
That question tells me. So it's not scary to anything. The rife machine is running the frequencies
that we have programmed in it. So it's hitting the that your cells at those frequencies. It's not
scanning the cancer or anything like that. So no, it's just a matter of taking time to heal.
And everybody's different. I've had patients literally say they felt much better just after
their two-day scan because during your two-day scan that you're in the office, you're actually being
treated with those frequencies that you're being scanned on. You can't help it. You're hitting the
body with frequencies. And you can feel better just after that. I've had people have noticeable
improvements in a couple of weeks, even off of lab work, that I've had people take three to six
months before there's changes. And in full disclosure, we've had people that we did everything possible
that we could possibly think of and we could not put the breaks on the cancer. So some things are
out of our control. We just have to try to do everything we possibly can. And that's always my
promise to all my patients. I believe that if patients going to come to us, if God's going to send
us somebody, it's my responsibility to try to figure out everything I possibly can. And I don't
you, although, don't know me very well, but I literally have no other hobbies. But to put some
around my yard and to think about another therapy or another treatment procedure or another angle
to try to attack cancer, it is a beast. I have a good friend who is a cancer researcher,
biologist at the University of Minnesota. He's been doing it for 30 years or so. A brilliant guy
he loves what we do. And he just says that it's just cancer. It's just so complex, it's difficult.
So I believe that the biggest reason why we have such a good success, right? And we do have such a good
success, right? It's not because of me and my great intelligence praise God that we don't have to rely
on that. But it's because God is good. And when you have the faith that that he's going to do his work
in his sovereignty through his plan in your job is to do your work that he has called you to whether
that be I'm going to work on my diet and I'm going to do the rife and I'm going to do some cleansing
and I'm going to try to clean up my lifestyle a little bit. And I'm allowing the cancer diagnosis
that I have to change by the way I look at life and deal with maybe anger and emotional things
and stress things that I had to deal with and allow it to change me, then I think you get better
results. Next question, what's it starts showing results? Will its actions speed up? Well, I wish we
could say that results go in a linear fashion, but they don't. Sometimes the patient does great with
the rife and then all of a sudden their cancer morphs and it's just trying to stay alive and grow.
So it changes its frequency and starts growing again. And we have to change the frequencies on the
rife machine. That's why I say we'll always do everything we possibly can. We'll tweak the program,
we'll tweak your nutritional piece, we'll tweak everything we can. Here's my concern, the rife
treatment will be outrun by the cancer itself, which is in a kind of a gallop right now. That's where
there can be benefits to using a more aggressive approach while you're doing an alternative approach
like this. So never what anybody there was some discussion on the Facebook page about chemotherapy.
I never want any of you guys to feel like you are ashamed because you are doing the chemotherapy
or radiation along with everything you're doing with us. That's legalism and that has no place in
my clinic and I hope it has no place in your heart. I don't want you guys to be dogmatic in your
approach. Meeting that I want you to think that doing a standard ecological approach is somehow
a kid to you giving up or a kid to you not having faith that a natural approach is going to work.
I don't want you to have faith in a natural approach. I want you to have faith in your
heavenly father and if he's leading you to a natural approach then follow that leading but if he's
leading you to a natural approach plus doing some chemo or radiation or surgery then by all means
you better darn well be immediate to that. And I don't want you feeling guilty because oh my goodness
you were doing so well on this but then you went back and did chemotherapy. Well praise god that
there's chemotherapy that we could use to knock this down. On the flip side of that we don't want
to run to and throw in fear and be making decisions in fear but we don't want to be foolish either. So
that's a balance between walking in foolishness and walking in fear. We don't want to do either. There's
wisdom in a multitude of counselors. It's good to seek other other approaches and other ideas.
I feel free to run it by me. Don't feel like you have to run away from us because you're going to
add chemotherapy to anything. For good of sakes we're here to get you better and we want to use every
means possible to get you better and I believe that god allowed humans to create chemotherapy for
that reason too. So don't ever shame yourself or shame others for doing that. I know nobody has
done that but don't feel ashamed for doing that. Okay so let's move on. Next question Dr. Cutters
told me a few weeks ago to stop juicy carrots until we knew the metabolism of my cells or the kids
or cells I assume that will be told of the DNA test or do we already know that it is told through
the DNA test exactly right. So when we look at your genetics test we're looking at specific pathways
that are going to tell us they're going to get a strong hints of how the cancer can be fed.
So if I have defects this is the one major pathway that we look at that tells us that we want to be
out of more keto-like diet and we better not be juicy carrots. Carrots are great and about
their high in sugar especially if we are juicy them. So we don't want to be juicy carrots if our
cancer is being fed through a glycolysis through what's called the warberg effect. So we'll look at
the LDH the PDH the HIF1 genes to see that if you do have a lot of defects in those genes then you're
going to be fed through this way we want to make sure that we're not getting too much sugar in our
diet. We'll go on a keto-like diet if that is the case. So if that is not the case that we could
go back to juicy carrots we just don't want to be feeding a growing cancer before we have
genetics back. So yes good question. Next question you sent me home with the personalized
specialized protocol for my situation. I'm grateful is this simply a baseline? So if you're talking
about your nutritional piece of your protocol is that a baseline? Well you could use it how you would.
Most of our patients are using it. That's all they're doing but we have some patients that are
studyers and they are seeking other things themselves too and there are other supplements too and they're
using some local practitioners as well that are tested about different things and suggested other
supplements and we also have a lot of people that have more than one condition. They don't have
just cancer they might have thyroid issues or they may have some adrenal issues or something else
they're on other supplements as well by all means that it's just a baseline. If you're talking about
the RIFE program it is not just a baseline. Well it depends on how much time you have and it depends
on how much time you are going to commit to doing other RIFE program. So typically a person who is
ambulatory who is up and about and functioning and living their life they're not I'm not asking
them to do any more RIFE treatment except maybe a foot bath treatment or something like that a
couple of times a week and many times on some of many of your programs I put some short programs
and the short programs in your folder are there for you to use. I think if you're going to sit down
watch a football game or read a book you might as well turn the RIFE and it gets a treatment while
you're doing it that's what those are for. Certainly you have 2,000 other programs in your RIFE machine
and you certainly have the right to have on their condition. So if you have let's say a colon cancer
but you also have some difficult irritation because you're 60 years old in a mail you might
want to run some prostate programs as well or if you have you know breast cancer and you also have
some Candida issues with your in your colon you can certainly run Candida programs as well. Utilize
the RIFE as much as possible it's a great tool again it's not but cure all in a magic one for
anything but it's a great tool we've had just phenomenal results with people and you can ask
people on Facebook their testimonies and how they've used the RIFE for all sorts of different things
and then yes it is a baseline in that sense. Continue the question I asked because I ran into the
10 pillars for treatment of cancer okay that's something that I wrote that that is out of my book
and yes could you add those things like oh in this pillar I don't remember with what they are
exactly but the procurement is in one of the pillars I know it should I add procurement to my
protocol well you can if you didn't test out for needing it you don't need to would it be helpful
yes it may this is where again I'm not running a legalistic clinic so I our clinic is based
upon grace in every aspect possible so if you believe you read something about we'll use the
procurement as an example and you feel really led to add procurement to your protocol then by all
means do that but I would recommend that you do ask a question on Facebook about if you're going to
use procurement which one do you so you don't just go buy Wal-Mart's turmeric which is not very good
and you won't absorb very much and you'll have to eat 10 grams of it to get you know one gram absorbed
so there may be some better best products out there that that maybe if you're going to spend the
money on something to spend the money on something that's going to be good for you so just ask those
questions but it's not a baseline in a sense that here's what I told you to do here's your protocol
now go add all the 10 pillar things and go add if let's say if I do a video on burberry oh my gosh I
gotta add burberry no it doesn't mean that it it if you feel led to add burberry then by all means do
that but I'm not in the business of selling supplements and I don't want my patients on 30-40
different things but I think that could be overload to your system it could be a bad thing so
do the things that you feel led to do constantly be seeking wisdom and my other writings and other
people's information and writings to be careful to balance it so that you're not fulfilling the
scripture I'm running to and fro and not resting in knowing that God's going to take care of you
through what you're doing too so have that balance I know that's a balance and I know it's difficult
sometimes and I know it's even more difficult I you know I don't know where everyone is spiritually
and not making judgments that way but honestly I cannot imagine going through my life without having
the counsel holy spirit in my life so that I could really get in a quiet time with my heavenly
father and say what am I supposed to do I I need to know what to do with this case with this problem
with this struggle that I'm having I do that what I think about you guys I can't imagine living my
life or I'm reliant it my own wisdom I would be I would be full of anxiety so I don't love that
for you either next question I have been doing intermittent coffee items for a while lately I read
that there's a lot of agreed science on this and that claims exist that it could kill people because
introducing bacteria you seem to be in favor of coffee edema's what are the cautions
the claims that it could kill people for introducing bacteria are true if you never washed the tip of
your coffee edema you'd ever cleaned your your coffee edema bag well then of course you could be
adding bacteria but you could say that with about anything you put in any orifice of your body so
to say that coffee edema's are bad and I might say this person is but whoever made a comment that
should do coffee edema's on the internet because it could kill people with the bacteria I would
challenge what they're putting in their mouth on a daily basis but that's another story so I find
that a little hilarious now there was instructions in your coffee edema bag if you got it from us
that's how to clean it you could certainly go online and Google how to keep your coffee edema bag
clean it can be advisable that you change this up every you know six months and get a new one
they're fairly easy to clean at least this what I think is great this is what I use it I think it's
very easy to clean so it's a matter of anything else you clean your figured nails and you wash
your fork before you eat supper anything you put in any orifice should be clean that's the
biography record temperatures of the surface of the skin or deeper in the tissues the biography is
only recording temperatures that exist whether those those temperatures are coming from lesions on
the surface or the temperature is increased at the surface because of lesions deeper in the tissue
that has to be understood through further examination so for instance here's a picture of
ATP be anterior to posterior these are in the person's arms chest breasts and this is the
white is the hottest you see the hottest underneath the breast here this is a female and you could say
oh my gosh there must be a lesion here there must be a lesion here and when a doctor says a lesion
that means a problem underneath there but then you have to use some um clinical skills to know that
no this is a lesion this is their under wire for their bra is here so it's increased the heat of
that area because it they wore their bra in and or their breast if the person is larger breast
than this maybe their breast was saggy doubt will increase heat there it's not a lesion there
so the purpose of the biography is to get clues to where there could be problems so in this person's case
this person's left breast could have some issues up here you can see it's draining to the armpit this
is you have to understand the lymphatic draining of the area this person could have issues with
their left breast um no real issues with their right breast but again you'd look at other
views I just grabbed this one a to p view off of the internet to show you um could have issues with
the thyroid up here could have issues with lymphatic drainage it warrants further investigation and
examination so the purpose of their biography is to give us clues where there could be lesions where
there could be some sort of pathology some sort of problem that we want to look at second half
of this question are the variable light frequency variations I think they're asking are there
is the programed in their night program um in the last hour or so of their nightly sessions more
important period of the session I think the person's asking this question because they might be getting
up earlier than the program is uh as long so they're getting up leaving bed and it's still
running for half hour 45 minutes an hour if this is happening every night you do want to contact us
we can shorten the dwell so that you're not just I don't let's say wasting but you're not getting
the frequencies of the last hour the most of the time we're recycling those frequencies so those are
still built into the program but we're getting a lot of frequencies in people's programs lately
so um we don't want you to be missing the last hour every single night so if you're like hey
I've never getting the full program ever well then we might want to shorten up a little bit so that
you're you're able to get the full program though typically I write the programs a little bit longer
than the average person would sleep knowing that you're not going to always get the end of it and it
is recycled in the beginning of the program but if you're at hour or so short every night consistently
make sure you let us know uh this is a funny question um so I made a little comment this person
I shortened their question a little bit it went to the dentist and uh they have to get some dental
work done and uh this person says I made a little comment that we will not be using fluoride
on me because I've read the science haven't believe it's a neurotoxin and it's a poison
I get told man quote I know the science better than you do well isn't that funny so you you get this
sometimes um doctors tend to be um sometimes I shouldn't say doctors is that's a little too
general but there's a lot of people that tend to get offended when you question their authority
and um huh that's unfortunate um now part of the problem is is that um doctors as well as you know
dentists have a procedure and they you know finances are dependent upon the procedures that they do
so it's real easy to justify different procedures whether it's good or bad for the person
um because you make money off of doing it unfortunately that is the truth of it so um for him to
basically attack the patients hey and I know the science better than you do um to me that would be
grounds right there to boy it's time to find another dentist the problem is if you're going to
a specialist there's only a few people in your area that do what you do or come or do your insurance
or something like that do what they do I mean it's difficult to do that you kind of got a smile
ago I met you do but this is what we're gonna do it's my mouth so I encourage you to take stand
and to be tough on it um she continues the question I'm still floored by the arguments I have been
getting uh into with this professional his wife is an oncologist uh you think there's an interest
getting interest in that I hope it's just funny so long story short what's our take on
fluoride so fluoride I put a little uh link here because uh I have a page on our website that I
devoted to uh dedicated to fluoride toxicity uh I am not a fan of fluoride in any way shape or form
I think it is very poisonous it is there's a lot of you could say conspiracy theory information
about fluoride that has been proven to not be conspiracy theory whatsoever it is toxic it's not good
for you um and if somebody on this call thinks is there a dentist or something it thinks completely
otherwise well I respect your decision and I just asked that you respect my opinion as well um I'm not
getting floored none of my kids are none of my great kids are forget it so um that's uh that's I think
you should the person who wrote this question hold your grounds um and if you continue to get pushed
back from this professional and you feel like you're kind of stuck because you have to stay with this
person um well then just try to try to um meet ice to him and um maybe it's a chance to be able to
really help this person with this to him and maybe three four years down the light he's going to go
oh there's something to this and he'll change his way so that would be wonderful
next question how much of what I see in the foot bath uh if Eddie is from me great question
so you can look online and you can see charts like this that oh you have green and yellow water this
is from the kidney bladder urinary tract uh orange water it's purified the joids brown it's coming
from the liver tobacco blah blah blah blah blah blah uh I don't know how much of this I agree with
I did write an article on this a number of years ago I don't know if it's still on our website or not
when we first started uh doing the ion cleanse that's a little bit different procedure than what
the what the ion pro wave is a little bit different technology and concept there uh but um of course
the salespeople for the company were like oh look at it sit down here and put your feet in there and
30 minutes later it's brown look at it pull it all this junk out of your body there's
some of truth to that but it's not completely true I was a skeptic complete skeptic so actually I
agreed because my staff was at the seminar with me when we uh got our first ion cleanse that we
got it uh like a three-month trial or something so I actually put it the the instrument in the water
and read it with nobody's feet in there and it did turn slightly tan but it not the same as
if you put somebody's feet in there so I do believe that part of the discoloration of the water
is the ionization of the minerals in the water and that's part of it um so I don't buy into this whole
thing completely and I certainly don't buy into that if you have white foam it's always from the
lymphatic system or if you have black flax it's always heavy metals because it's just not um and I've
always wanted to oh that's gonna take this over to my uh organic kin friend and have it analyzed
to see if there really are heavy metals in that water but I haven't ever gotten to that point but it's
it's um I think it's beneficial now if you're doing the ion pro wave that comes with the rife
that's a little different technology so the ion cleanse is a different type of instruments a different
machine altogether that you put the plates in the water it ionizes the water at positive for 50
percent of the time at negative for 50 percent of the time and then you will attract through just
ionization principles the opposite polarity out of your body and it'll pull out on the body
with the ion pro wave it's not doing that so it's not doing the exact same thing it's using it's
getting frequencies through the water um there is some ionization taking place but not as much as
with the iron cleanse that you're getting frequencies through that so you're actually it's just another
way to treat through frequencies uh and it could be beneficial now um what other way that you can test
if it's coming out of your body or not is the more you do it is the water getting less um uh colorful
and that is uh proven to be true with most patients so the logger they're doing it as
low as they're not continuing to toxify themselves the water's color is is slowly improving
but i don't believe that all the stuff that the color of the water is coming from that next part of
the question is am i i am doing a regular psa test through my local doctor would there be an advantage
doing an ivg test for a baseline uh if so what would be the advantage um i don't know i um the psa
if that has been a good marker for a person it is a much less expensive marker so the ivg test is
$450 the psa you could get it done for 50 bucks or something you're probably through your insurance
free so that has been a big advantage you're really just looking for markers so when you're looking for
how am i progressing with my cancer is what i'm doing working or not working you're looking for
what are some the least invasive markers because we could do a CT scan we could do a CT scan every
month and see how it's progressing or not progressing the negative is that's what a whole heck of a lot
of radiation and you will be glowing by the end of the year and no one would be able to be around
you it did a 12 foot radius so that's not an option so we could do a MRI doesn't have the radiation
but then you have to use gadolidium as a dye you could have gadolidium toxicity and you got the
magnetic field that's so strong that could mess with your e-mf so your body and that's that always a
good choice either especially if you're gonna have to do a lot of them and then what else we're going
to do well if we have thyroid cancer what else are we going to measure you know that's the
cancer markers might show up there if we have colon cancer maybe a CEA 125 might show up but it might
not show up so the cancer markers don't always work so not everybody not everybody's kids are really
elicits the tuber markers so those don't always work so how do we know we're getting better or not
well the PSA test can give us an indication now what I mentioned on Facebook is that you have to be
careful with any marker the tuber markers what day first came up the CA1719 and the CEA 125 with those
were first discovered that you know we thought that was the hottest thing said slice bread the problem
is when you undergo any care on which persons typically getting those markers done through their
oncologist and then they're doing chemotherapy the cancer markers can spike because the cancer is
dying quickly and and then the patient can freak out and go oh my gosh I thought this was supposed to
help me you know I'm actually getting worse worse you know they're their their CEA 125 you know
went up to a thousand or something like that and the level of anxiety can be great and the oncologist
simply does not have time devoted to trying to talk person off of jumping off the high bridge because
um he needs to explain the science that what we do chemotherapy it's very often to have a cancer
marker spike um and that's hard for people to understand and buy into what a whitage tell me that before
why are you continuing to do it that's why a lot of a lot of oncologists we get less and less
of our patients come in that even had those cancer markers tested because a lot of oncologists like
and I had that discussion you know one time with you know with a patient and it was a nightmare where
does that run in those tests anymore so PSA can be the same thing so just understand that
but it's a cheap marker so if it's been used in the past and if that's what you've been
following um then it's good to keep following that marker and know that it can go up and it can
go down and just we're just going to keep an eye on it and even though I know that okay we're
going to start a course of alternative care here and let's say your PSA goes up and I know that hey
that actually could be a good thing because we're killing off the cancer how do we know that's true
well we could go and do a CT scan uh no you can't because nothing is going to be perfect no
test is going to be perfect and I know we live in a day an age where we think that there is this
just objectivity to the practice of medicine and if we just do this gold standard CT scan pet scan
then I will know if beyond a shadow of a doubt that I am all cleaned or that I'm not all cleaned
it is just not that easy and it's not that simple and there's so much object or subjectivity
in that testing and reading that test and even subjectivity in the instrumentation of how it's done
so there really is so perfect test out there even the highly invasive ones are far from perfect
it's just you just have to understand that that's with any medical testing so again I don't want you
to put your faith in a test as much as I don't want you to put your faith in the right machine or
doctor counters or some supplement or doctor oncologist you can't do that and we are we're fleshly
human beings and that's our first go to is I want to put my faith in something so that I know I'm okay
guess what at least I'll just tell you in my life God never lets me into the false comfort zone
of being okay I never feel okay from a physical standpoint and from an emotional standpoint all
the reason why I know I'm okay is because I know I'm rested in the hands of my Heavenly Father
and I trust him however he deals with my life and this is where you know I cannot emphasize complete
surrender if I'm completely surrendered to my Heavenly Father then my role then I'm his child
and he wants to take care of me he just wants me to climb up in his lap and he wants to hold me
and tell me that he's got an under control and that I don't have an under control and that's very
difficult for me because I want to have an under control I'm a control freak and because I'm a control
freak he makes sure because he loves me so much to reveal to me that I am never going to have an
under control so that's what keeps me in complete dependence upon him and that's what keeps me in a state
of surrender every day because then I pull back and I want to have it all figured out and I want to get
it down and I want to have it all objective and I want to know I'm moving in the right direction
and I want to know I'm getting everything that I want I suppose to rug on from under my feet
did honestly I think he does it I don't he does it because he loves me so much
he does not want me to rely on myself he keeps me completely dependent upon him
and that's why he's called me to help people like you honestly I would rather just be a nice
little little car parker who doesn't have to be responsible for everything it's good just your
atlas you don't feel better well than you're just going to real doctor but it's not my problem
and that would have been a whole lot easier or I'm just going to be an organic chemist and I could
just go to lab every day and figure out a new way to create a dry toner for black printer cartridges
and I never have to talk to he would be and I never have to deal with any conflict I get my paycheck
go home and I'm not knocking anybody that's chosen that profession but he has not chosen that
profession for me he's always kept me on pins and needles so that I stay in a 100% state of
dependence on him and what I don't it's very obvious to everybody because I'm screwing up
so I'll get off my soapbox here but I really want to emphasize that to you that yes to answer this
question in 15 minutes I apologize could you do the IBG for a baseline you certainly can IBG
is a perfect test either nor is the PSA and we've seen the IBG go up when we start people under care
we've seen the IBG go down we start people under care and nobody has the answers to why that always
happens and again we put that our faith back in our Heavenly Father and we say Lord is there anything
else that we need to do am I missing something it's good to ask those questions and to seek wisdom daily
but then rest in that he's in control okay so we had another question that came in on the chat
there is a YouTube video discouraging the use of wheatgrass claims that wheatgrass contains
prolamine which is a form of gluten claims that it is a nutrient blocker plus causes inflammation do you
know if this is true at all so what I do know is that wheatgrass if you are picking it before 12 days hold
it does not contain that so if you're growing your own wheatgrass and you're thinking you're
going to let it grow longer because you're going to get more value out of it and you're growing it
you know for the 12 days and then you're clipping it that yeah that is true it could have that it
could contain gluten it could contain prolamine and it could cause all those inflammation and be
worse for you than it really is but if you're clipping it young eating within the week that it's
tight then you're avoiding all that at least that's the knowledge that I know that's out there so
I will open it up to questions even though we're running a little bit late here but if there be
one or two questions feel free to jump in nothing all right well I'm going to mute everybody and I
will say goodbye please email your questions in just like these we got a number of them in
and we'll make sure that we answer them also you feel free to use Facebook
or if you also want to ask to post a question on Facebook anonymously for you
I've never said that before I keep forgetting to make this announced but feel free to email us a
question say please post this anonymously so we'll post a question say to a patient ask this question
if you don't want everybody to know that you have total fungus or something like that
and we can help by posting the answer so that we don't have to do it on zoom but we can do it on the
Facebook page and everybody get the advantage off of that if you don't want to post that so feel free
to do that all right I'll be praying for you guys I do ask that you continue to pray for us
and we will talk very soon love you all bye bye